hi i'm bowen yang and i'm here with
buzzfeed today to read thirst tweets oh
i hope i get a boyfriend out of this
[Music]
okay first tweet i just want to kiss bo
and yang just one time okay um they're
already putting a cap on it just one
time i like a nice progression up like
first time let's keep the lips unparted
we build up
throat play anyways i hope bowen yang
knows how much he means to my gay asian
ass i love him so much that's so nice i
wish this person was just like an ethnic
frankenstein and they had a gay asian
ass and you know a lesbian irish tit the
other tit can be anything and then the
third tip can be specifically um
brazilian is bow and yang single bone if
you see this before wednesday night i
want you to know that i am free on
wednesday night and if you're free on
wednesday night i would like to get
dinner with you on wednesday night when
i am free this is really sweet wednesday
nights are tough either i am watching
real housewives of beverly hills or i'm
at work and i'm waiting for the pics to
go out for each week at snl or i'm maybe
just spinning out at home in private
wednesdays are tough i'm not usually
free but this person seems really nice i
want to quit my job to become the little
sparkle in bow and yang's eyes my eyes
are really dull actually so i don't know
what this person's talking about i get a
little bit of reflection on them when i
put contacts in because the reflective
index is different than my actual
eyeballs but sparkle that's a stretch
and does this person want to [ __ ] me i
don't know i can't tell next one oh
bowen yang's got that body audio body
noted that's really nice it's certainly
not like an italian level it's certainly
not courtney act level i have a
remarkably short torso i make it work
but like the space between like the
bottom of my ribs to my hip bone is like
maybe
two centimeters long just kidding it's
more than that but it's just it's just
not i'm not working with much like waste
here so anytime you know someone tries
to cinch me which is a lot they're like
oh there's nothing there everybody's
different everybody's beautiful brackets
get stabbed by bow and yang brackets
blood coming out of my mouth thanks
king dead emoji that's like best case
scenario if you were to stab someone and
they thanked you you'd be like that went
so much better than i thought it would
can anybody get a message to boeing for
me can you tell him i'm still waiting
for him to match with me on tinder since
i paid five dollars to be able to swipe
right what's that business model tinder
i mean
the super likes the tinder gold the
tinder plus i call freemium bullsh on
that whole thing love tinder have had c
plus dates thanks to you guys and i will
always cherish them but he made this
poor person pay five dollars so that he
could potentially match with me and that
feels like a scam bow and yang can spit
in my mouth hearted lips emoji what's it
called when you're like the receptive
partner to spit that's what i am so i'm
like a spit bottom
i guess i'm here to coin mussy busy with
an m
you do the math this is a taran edgerton
moment for all of you who are now
learning what the word musty is i have a
great musty
no thoughts just leather daddy bow and
yang hashtag oh this is when i dressed
up as the um leather daddy village
person as part of this village people
thing we did on snl on weekend update
you should check it out something about
a handlebar mustache really works on me
and my hair follicles on my actual face
will never ever ever grant me that i'm
not fully hairless okay
all i want is for bow and yang to
message me on grinder oh grinder duh
just kidding i knew what he meant while
i'm in the city oh so this person is
visiting darn it i would love to be like
the sexual equivalent of you know
tickets to hamilton at balthazar bakery
moments the glossier flagship i would
love to be like a new york city
attraction like come to the city and
you're lucky if you have the right
concierge at your hotel they might be
able to get you a message from me on
grindr what am i saying nobody nothing
me i would top bo and yang
okay i mean great this is as wonderfully
transactional as i want any interaction
to be preceding sex nobody says anything
literally nobody says a word and this
person
says to nobody i would topo i mean and
if i somehow got wind of that i would be
like great i'm obsessed with bo and
yang's mouth you mean my music next
tweet pov it's 20 22. bar's open no yang
is standing drinking his gin martini oh
this person knows me well i love a gym
routine i see him you can centrally kiss
the point he slaps me as he should and
walks away i
this is such a rich text there's so much
going on here there's a beginning a
middle and an end i know what time this
takes place in i know
so much information bars open okay so
we're in a postcoded world like hope it
has happened this is not an alternate
timeline i slap him as i should
that's so rich i want more of that so
we're workshopping this tweet and i
think there's so much here this person
can really really really expand this
world and i'm really curious to know
what happens in it jualippa got to touch
bow and yang's ass and now i have yet
another reason to be jealous of her look
that is the last thing you should be
jealous about when it comes to alibaba
she has a million other great things
going for her the last good thing
i'll say it's a good thing that she
touched my ass i hope it's a highlight
for her and her life that she got to
touch my ass but you know dream bigger
this person can touch my ass if it will
make them feel less jealous of do alipa
bowen yang is so cute i thought he's a
porn star i thought he's a porn star
poetic porn stars are so cool like now
it's like in order to be a porn star you
have to like know a bunch about like
philosophy the drop gets harder and
harder as the years go by like people
have to be like sapiosexually attracted
to you and sexually attracted to you
it's a high pressure job it was always a
high pressure job and now it's like you
gotta check every box for a lot of
people some people do it great i would
not i would not do it great yeah i'm a
[ __ ] for bow and yang that's so
beautiful these are all poems i'm
reading thirst poems for buzzfeed last
tweet yeah i just want to eat bow and
yang's ass
the casual sort of tossing it off yeah i
just want to eat bow and yang's ass just
feels so effortless it should just feel
like you know you're ordering something
at the jelly like uh yeah i'll do
salsa dick and cheese on a kaiser roll
it should be that like airy i love that
i've never really expressed that about
someone in such a lackadaisical manner
and i really admire that and even
attracted to it thank you so much
buzzfeed for presenting me with all of
these wonderful poems beat your beat to
that as much as you want on sunday if
that's what you like to do i am not here
to yuck anyone's yum especially if the
um is me please watch aquafina is nor
from queens season two premiering august
18th on comedy central at 10 9 central
[Music]
you